hoffnungsschimmer vor weihnachten
bereits am kommenden montag will die
europäische arzneimittelbehörde über die
zulassung des corona impfstoffs
entscheiden
dicht an dicht am letzten tag vor dem
shutdown deutschlands einkaufsstraßen
melden geschenke trubel lastminute und
bestätigung für joe biden die us
wahlleute bescheinigen einen deutlichen
sieg des gewählten us-präsidenten nur
der amtsinhaber will das weiter nicht
wahrhaben
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sieber und der wünsche ihnen
allen einen guten abend gemeinsam mit
kristin otto die sich heute um den sport
kümmert der sende voller vor der guten
abend die korona lage in deutschland ist
so ernst wie nie sagt der chef des
robert koch instituts und befürchtet
dass sie noch schlimmer werden könnte
gleichzeitig ist seit heute klar dass es
tatsächlich schon vor weihnachten auch
bei uns mit dem impfen losgehen könnte
stichtag ist der 21 dezember dann will
die europäische arzneimittelbehörde
sagen ob sie den impfstoff zulässt ihr
okay gilt als so gut wie sicher
schon kurz danach sollen dann die
impfungen in europa beginn heike slansky
wie war die erste die geimpft wurde in
großbritannien mit dem impfstoff made in
germany eine notfall zulassung hatte es
möglich gemacht ein verfahren dass alle
anderen eu länder abgelehnt hatten für
sie gilt sorgfalt stadt schnelligkeit
von anfang an gesagt wir machen keine
not zulassung sondern eine ordentliche
zulassung weil es darum geht vertrauen
in das impfen grad in dieser pandemie
auch bestmöglich zu gewinnen und zu
erhalten
nun könnte es auch in allen anderen eu
ländern bald losgehen
noch vor weihnachten will die zuständige
europäische arzneimittelagentur
entscheiden eine gute nachricht in
schlechten zeiten
die lage ist so ernst wie sie noch nie
war in dieser pandemie die fallzahlen
sind insgesamt zu hoch wie nie und sie
steigen weiter an
die gefahr besteht dass sie die
situation weiter verschlimmert und es
damit immer schwieriger wird mit der
partie mit ihren folgen umzugehen
der impfstoff als lichtblick die meisten
impfzentren stehen bereit die
risikogruppen älterer und vor erkrankte
sollen vorrang haben denn für alle
reicht der impfstoff erst einmal nicht
aus es muss nicht gewartet werden bis
die eine gruppe komplett durch geimpft
ist sondern man kann zumindest die
ersten gruppen parallel impfen da es
unterschiedliche geschwindigkeiten und
auch praktische herausforderungen geben
wird die frage
wer zuerst geimpft wird gehöre in den
bundestag so die opposition
wenn es um fragen wortwörtlich von leben
und tod geht dann muss der deutsche
bundestag über die prioritäten folge
beim impfen entscheiden
wir schlagen ein impf gesetz vor impfen
vielleicht schon zum jahresende twittert
eu-kommissarin von der leyen und
trotzdem wird die pandemie noch lange
nicht aus der welt sein
besondern mal nachfragen bei stefan
leifert in brüssel genannt stefan
handelt die behörde jetzt unter dem
druck den die staaten da machen oder war
das tatsächlich noch luft in ihrem
ursprünglichen zeitplan
die zulassungsbehörde verwahrt sich
vehement gegen den vorwurf hier
irgendwie unter politischen druck
gestanden zu haben
der war wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht
nötig denn dort ist jedem bewusst worum
es geht der konkrete grund dafür dass
man die entscheidung jetzt um ein paar
tage oder fast eine woche nach vorne
gezogen hat war das über nacht noch mal
neue datensätze vom hersteller biontech
gekommen sind und diese datengrundlage
die dort jetzt vorliegt bei der
zulassungsbehörde die reiche aus um am
21.12 also am nächsten montag eine
entscheidung zu treffen
welches land wie viel impfstoff bekommt
das regelt die eu was heißt das für
deutschland
die eu kommission hat sich vertraglich
insgesamt zwei milliarden impfdosen
gesichert und die werden ganz schlicht
nach einem schlüssel verteilt er sich
nach der bevölkerungsgröße richtet und
deutschland stehen demnach 18,6 prozent
zu
das schließt aber nicht aus dass
einzelne länder darüber hinaus noch
eigene verträge mit herstellern
geschlossen haben für deutschland ist
dass beispielsweise der fall einen eu
weit einheitlichen impfstart termin den
muss und den soll es nicht geben aber
dennoch haben sich einige länder schon
zusammengeschlossen
deutschland frankreich italien und fünf
weitere länder wollen sich da
koordinieren damit es keinen wettlauf um
die erste spritze gibt hier in brüssel
geht man davon aus dass beginn der
impfung an den weihnachtstagen sein wird
stefan herzlichen dank und damit stellen
sich jetzt noch in diesem jahr ganz
konkrete fragen zur impfung wer wie man
antworten von thomas konsum
sie rückt näher schneller als gedacht
die impfung mit dem corona wirkstoff in
deutschland sobald die eu-behörde und
danach die kommission entschieden haben
soll ist zügig vorangehen so der
bundesgesundheitsminister schnelle
prüfung der chargen dann schnelle
lieferungen so dass ich maximal mit zwei
bis vier tagen späteren im staat rechnen
heisst also läuft es gut könnte es ab
heiligabend die ersten impfungen geben
konkret läuft das so wer impft
berechtigt ist bekommt bescheid wohl per
post oder über den hausarzt zuerst
erhalten den impfstoff etwa bewohner
innen und personal in pflegeheimen über
80-jährige und medizinisches personal
sie bekommen den wirkstoff in
impfzentren die stehen seit heute bereit
etwa in der messe köln oder in ingelheim
bei mainz terminvergabe passiert
telefonisch dh zu impfenden personen
kommen hier an dann wird geprüft ob sie
berechtigt sind und dann werden die
personen hier aufgenommen
herzlich aufgeklärt und gehen dann eben
in dem straße um sich impfen zu lassen
und das wenn alles klappt vielleicht
wirklich schon zu weihnachten ihre
fragen zum thema impfen können sie
gleich stellen bei zdf heute live an den
impfstoff forscher telekom ab halb acht
auf zdf heute facebook und youtube
heute ist der letzte tag mit geöffneten
geschäften in deutschland ab morgen gilt
der shutdown dann müssen die
allermeisten schließen
das heißt heute auch noch mal volle
einkaufsstraßen
das weihnachtsgeschäft ist damit für die
händler allerdings alles andere als
gerettet und auch im kampf gegen die
pandemie ist das eher bedenklich zumal
heute auch noch ein ansturm auf die
apotheken losging
dort gibt es jetzt schutzmasken für
besonders gefährdete gratis pedro neubau
schnell noch das letzte geschenk
besorgen bevor deutschland herunter
fährt es wuselt in den innenstädten wie
hier in münchen viel zu viele menschen
dennoch irgendwo
kann ich die leute auch verstehen dass
ihr das jetzt noch ausnutzen wollen
daheim hat man halt immer allein oder in
der wg oder sowas und jetzt hier wieder
so viele menschen ist man gewohnt
ich arbeite selber im klinikum und ich
bin einfach nur froh wenn ich auch mal
was anderes
franz klug würde in seiner münchner
buchhandlung gerne noch mehr kunden
bedienen die abstandsregeln aber
erlauben nur sechs menschen auf einmal
im laden und ab morgen ist ganz schluss
diese woche fällt uns jetzt also wie es
fehlt uns im jahresumsatz das heißt
wahrscheinlich im nächsten jahr werden
viele buchen leute entlassen müssen weil
einfach der umsatz zu wenig war zum
großen trubel kommt der ansturm auf die
apotheken
dort gibt es für risikogruppen seit
heute kostenlose ffp zwei masken die
einen besseren schutz versprechen nach
hause maximilian lernbecher und sein
team seit dem frühen morgen im einsatz
innerhalb einer stunde kamen rund 100
kunden das wirklich hören können hier
sind bevorratet und vorbereitet gewesen
aber dass so viel auf einmal kommt hat
uns dann doch überrascht das abholen und
warten vor den apotheken aber bringt
wieder kontakte die eigentlich vermieden
werden sollen
es wäre kontraproduktiv wenn wir jetzt
ältere herrschaften aus der pause in
inneren quarantäne herauslockt wir geben
das großzügig mit
wenn der angehörige kommen die belassen
es dann auch im namen der angehörigen
quasi unterschreiben die gratis masken
abgabe läuft zwar bis januar viele aber
können es gar nicht erwarten
gestern wurde dort als christen ab heute
gibt es wenn sie ankommen so drängt
heute alles in die innenstädte kontakt
beschränkungen an diesem tag eher
schwierig und die aktuellen corona
zahlen ergeben sich aus den gemeldeten
positiven testergebnissen und sie sehen
so aus laut robert koch institut meldete
die gesundheitsämter 14.400 32 neue
fälle
nicht dabei sind zahlen aus sachsen
wegen einer technischen panne auch ohne
die sind es 378 neuinfektionen mehr als
vor einer woche
500 menschen sind innerhalb eines tages
an oder mit dem virus gestorben
jetzt schauen wir auf einer gruppe die
ihre corona sorgen gar nicht besonders
laut äußert aber eine menge darf
man hat die fast drei millionen
studierenden in deutschland die an einer
hochschule eingeschrieben sind diese
aber allenfalls von außen sehen
vorlesungen und seminare all das findet
fast nur noch online statt heute
berichteten sie auch der bundeskanzlerin
in einer video schalte von ihrem leben
bei den eltern statt in der studenten-wg
von gestrichenen praktiker weggefallenen
jobs und von einsamkeit wie sich
studieren 2020 anfühlt dazu hinken
klinge an ihrer hochschule in wiesbaden
sind leer honig und kathi richter fast
nie denn hier findet aktuell kaum etwas
stadt die beiden studieren im vierten
semester der media management und kathi
innenarchitektur
im moment ist das hart für sie im
vergleich zu den ersten beiden semestern
die ja ganz normal life waren habe ich
einfach das gefühl ich kann den inhalt
nicht wirklich fassen also dass ich halt
mehr videos mehrfach anschaue und nie
das gefühl habe wie nach einer vorlesung
wo ich rausgehe und gedacht habe okay
habe ich jetzt verstanden
man habe die ganze zeit im home office
und man ist praktisch seiner studienzeit
beraubt und das wird nicht wieder kommen
jetzt die zeit auch wenn das erst zwei
semester sind aber es ist halt nun mal
ein jahr schon fast und ich vermisse
meine freunde meine kommilitonen
unglaublich und ich hatte mich so
gefreut immer zu studieren die hörsäle
leer nur einige praktische kurse dürfen
angeboten werden für wenige studierende
professor volker blees von der
hochschule sagt es läuft grundsätzlich
gut er merkt aber auch dass sich weniger
als sonst zu prüfungen anmelden also die
probleme sind sicher dass studierende
die vor allem in gruppen gut lernen
können die werden abgehängt weil
gruppenarbeit funktioniert so nicht so
gut und vor allem den höheren semestern
komplexe sachverhalte zu diskutieren im
diskurs mit den studierenden das
funktioniert erheblich schlechter als in
den präsenz format der honig ist auch in
der studierendenvertretung der
hochschule aktiv und bemerkt dass viele
ihrer kommilitonen finanzielle sorgen
haben weil ihnen aktuell ihre
studentenjobs wegbrechen
zurück zu den eltern wissen nicht
lea hat glück sie erhält ein stipendium
und kommt gut zurecht inhaltlich hofft
sie dass es möglichst bald weitergeht
real in der hochschule auch viele
unserer europäischen nachbarn sind von
der zweiten corona welle massiv
getroffen und deshalb gilt in tschechien
die erst seit kurzem geöffneten hotels
und gaststätten müssen wieder schließen
italien will weitere verschärfungen über
die feiertage und die niederlande sind
seit heute dann im strikten shutdown die
meisten läden sind zu museen friseure
fitness studios geschlossen
wegen der hohen corona zahlen aber auch
weil die regierung befürchtet dass die
nachbarn aus deutschland sonst ihre
weihnachtseinkäufe jenseits der grenze
erledigen und damit zu unserem nächsten
thema heute abend die amerikanischen
tech giganten google amazon facebook
apple dominieren weite teile des
internets
jetzt will die eu ihnen deutliche
grenzen setzen und hat dafür ein
gesetzesvorhaben präsentiert brüssel
will verhindern dass die konzerne ihre
marktmacht immer weiter ausbauen und
missbrauchen
so sollen tech giganten mit mehr als 45
millionen nutzern in ihrem einfluss
beschnitten werden
bei regelverstößen drohen hohe strafen
und die unternehmen müssen sich
verpflichten strafrechtlich relevante
inhalte schnell von ihren seiten zu
löschen
nachfrage bei unseren
wirtschaftsexperten frank bethmann frank
wie sehr muss denn dass diese riesen
konzerne jetzt beeindruckend was sie da
hören aus brüssel
naja unbeeindruckt sie nicht es wird
aber trotzdem nicht einfach ihre
marktmacht zu brechen was brüssel will
ist klar irgendwann ein schärferes
schwert als bisher in der hand zu halten
ein instrument mit dem man milliarden
strafen verhängen kann
es geht aber noch um etwas anderes
nämlich die großen player dazu zu
verpflichten stärker gegen illegales
geschäft vorzugehen
beispielsweise zu verhindern dass andere
marktteilnehmer auf ihren großen
plattformen gefälschte produkte
verkaufen können oder nicht illegal aber
problematisch die angesprochenen
internetriesen werten bisher die daten
ihrer kunden aus damit soll künftig
schluss sein
noch sind das vorhaben und keine gesetze
doch es wird höchste zeit für strengere
regeln 20 jahre ist es her dass die eu
umfassende regeln für digitale dienste
und
online plattform aufgestellt hat
zeitgemäß sind sie schon lange nicht
mehr
frank vielen dank für diese
erläuterungen heute abend und dann
schauen wir in die usa dort ist es jetzt
auch offiziell was seit wochen klar ist
joe biden wird der neue der 46 präsident
der vereinigten staaten
die mitglieder des wahlleute gremiums
haben seine wahl bestätigt exakt wie
erwartet mit 306 zu 232 stimmen folgten
sie dem wählerwillen ohne einen einzigen
abweichler
während der amtsinhaber weiter unwahre
behauptungen verbreitet gratulieren auch
wichtige republikaner arbeiten jetzt zum
wahlsieg britta jäger die wahlleute
haben es offiziell und mit nachdruck
bestätigt joe biden wird der nächste us
präsident am abend richtet der sieger
das wort an die nation mord flamme der
demokratie wurde in dieser nation vor
langer zeit entzündet und wir wissen
jetzt dass nichts nicht einmal eine
pandemie oder machtmissbrauch diese
flamme auslöschen kann die abstimmung
der wahlleute ist üblicherweise reine
formsache
und doch war die aufmerksamkeit dieses
mal besonders groß weil donald trump
zuvor erfolglos versucht hatte den sieg
bei uns in einigen bundesstaaten zu
kippen
in michigan etwa gingen die wahlleute
unter polizeischutz zur abstimmung
nachdem sie todesdrohungen enttäuschter
trump anhänger erhalten hatten
dennoch gab es landesweit keine abwegige
pippo
das volk hat gesprochen es war eine
faire und sichere was auch immer mehr
führende mitglieder der republikanischen
partei lenken nun ein akzeptieren
offiziell beiden sieg darunter der
mehrheitsführer im senat mitch mcconnell
seit heute morgen hat unser land einen
neu gewählten präsidenten und eine neu
gewählte vizepräsident in das wahlleute
gremium hat entschieden
also möchte ich die beiden heute grad
am abend zuvor nahm justizminister war
seinen hut unsere beziehung war sehr gut
schrieb auf twitter
dabei hatte sich barth zuletzt mit
seinem chef überworfen weil er bei
dessen wahlbetrugs kampagne nicht
mitziehen wollte als 2014 die
terrorgruppe boko haram hunderte mädchen
in nigeria verschleppte ging die
nachricht um die welt
jetzt hat sich boko haram wieder zu
einer grausamen entführung bekannt im
norden von nigeria in kanada haben
bewaffnete männer eine schule überfallen
weil die kinder dort westlich und
islamfeindlich erzogen würden wie es in
einer bekenner botschaft heißt von der
örtliche medien berichten
mehr als 300 kinder und jugendliche
werden seitdem vermisst
schreckliche geschichte jetzt machen
einschnitt in der sendung und hoffen auf
bessere nachrichten fuß und handball
jetzt mit christine genau der ball rollt
englische woche mit der chance für
borussia dortmund nach drei liga spielen
ohne sieg nun unter dem neuen
cheftrainer edin terzic zurück in die
erfolgsspur zu kommen
erste bewährungsprobe am abend bei
werder bremen viel zeit für
veränderungen hat der neue trainer nicht
gehabt daher standen vor allem intensive
gespräche im mittelpunkt also mannschaft
hat so viel gutes gezeigten den letzten
zweieinhalb jahren dass ich glaube dass
es am schnellsten geht indem wir das
mindset etwas etwas justieren dass wir
wieder an die eigene stärke zurück
erinnern
gegner war der bremen hat seit acht
ligaspielen nicht mehr gewonnen
die tatsache dass beim bvb jetzt nicht
mehr lucien favre das sagen hat
erleichtert die sache heute abend nicht
da hat sich unsere vorbereitung die wir
haben also im trainerteam natürlich
verändert aber es hat sich auch das
verändert was wir der mannschaft zeigen
werden noch ist eben nicht klar wie der
neue chef beim bvb seine mannschaft
spielen
weitere absagen für die handball
weltmeisterschaft in ägypten finn lemke
steffen weinhold und hendrik pekeler
verzichten ebenfalls freiwillig wegen
der korona pandemie auf die endrunde und
erfolgsdruck bei den handballerinnen nur
mit einem sieg und zwei toren mehr gegen
kroatien erreichen sie bei der em in
kolding dänemark das halbfinale
daran änderte auch nichts die knappe
niederlage gegen die niederländerinnen
gegen diese kommt es vor allem auf die
defensivleistung an nur auf torfrau
diener eckerle wie gegen die niederlande
sollte man sich nicht verlassen
sie parierte 40 prozent der würfe war
maßgeblich daran beteiligt dass man den
weltmeister lange am rande der
niederlage hatte ja auch ein sieg gegen
holland hätte uns da nicht
weitergebracht überhaupt finale
wir hatten gegen kroatien gewinnen
müssen was man auch besser nutzen sollte
sind die eigenen möglichkeiten auch wenn
tess wester wie auf der gegenseite
eckerle herausragend agierte
gewinnt deutschland heute abend mit
mindestens zwei toren gegen kroatien ist
das halbfinale erreicht und damit der
ärger wie nach dem spiel gegen die
niederlande vergessen halbfinale wäre
erstmal ist 2008 lange zeit und wäre
schön
super christin vielen dank gern hoffnung
und zuversicht davon können wir gerade
eine extra portion gebrauchen gerne auch
in ganz groß gerne auch ganz fett auf
dem amtssitz des bundespräsidenten
stärker zusammen um stärker denn je zu
werden oder deutschland bleibt cool
bleibt bunt das sind nur zwei von den
botschaften von bürgern an der fassade
von schloss bellevue und bis donnerstag
auch jeden abend auf der internetseite
des bundespräsidenten
gedacht als kleines großes zeichen des
zusammenhalts und der zuversicht zum
ende eines schwierigen jahres ein
lichtblick auch beim wetter zumindest
etwas sonne ist morgen dabei mehr gleich
von besten terry 21 uhr 45 zeit für das
heute-journal zeit für den kollegen
claus kleber wer soll und muss zuerst
dran sein bei der impfung fragen an die
vorsitzende des ethikrats wir freuen uns
auf sie auch morgen danken für heute und
wünsche ihnen allen einen angenehmen
[Musik]
schön kunde und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter das frontensystem das uns den
regen brachte zieht allmählich nach
osten ab dass der vorschau film bis
morgen abend um zu sehen hier
da erreicht uns dann im tagesverlauf ein
hoch und beruhigt das ganze ein zeichen
für ruhiges wetter ist der nebel zum
beispiel im südosten deutschlands oder
im westen
ansonsten zieht hier dieser regen im
osten deutschlands allmählich ab und
auch im südwesten wird es trockener bei
tiefsten temperaturen von sieben grad
nach norden und minus 1 grad an der
donau und morgen im tagesverlauf lässt
der regen allmählich nach und hier und
da lockert es auf vor allem wenn der
nebel verschwindet zum beispiel im
westen und im südwesten und an den alpen
und dann kommt die sonne hervor bei
höchsten temperaturen von drei grad an
der donau und 12 grad im südwesten
deutschlands die kommenden tage am
donnerstag gibt es regen im nordwesten
ansonsten teils sonniges wetter an vor
allem nach nebelauflösung bei zwei bis
elf grad
am freitag wird es ebenfalls ruhig sein
sowie am samstag und die temperaturen
insgesamt bei 2 bis 13 grad
damit ein schöner amt